si tú no haces gol durante siete
partidos pues claramente demuestras que
tienes problemas el primer problema fue
que comenzando el ciclo para el mundial
o sea después de la salida de rusia con
aquel empate ante inglaterra y la
derrota por penales en el estadio
spartak moscú se dilató muchísimo la
salida de pekerman era un ciclo cumplido
según los directivos y después recién en
febrero después de terminar la
participación de la copa de asia
dirigiendo a irán es que llega carlos
queirós y colombia perdió seis o siete
meses de trabajo ese fue el primer punto
en contra luego aparece la copa américa
no sale de la mejor manera perdiendo
ante chile en los cuartos de final en
sao paulo en la cancha de corinthias y
bien en idas y vueltas y perderte en
todo este tiempo un partido ante argelia
en francia en lille en que el entrenador
se equivoca el el equipo empieza con
altas y bajas nunca convenció llegar ese
par de partidos el 30 ante uruguay en
barranquilla y el 61 en quitó en la
cancha de liga de quito que determinan
la salida de carlos queirós y aparece a
tapar una vez más un hueco reinaldo
rueda quien ya ha gastado encargado del
equipo para la eliminatoria del 2000 y
nunca recibió el voto de confianza a
vino a tapar un hueco y lastimosamente
no ha podido la irregularidad de los
futbolistas también juego en contra de
colombia algunos lesionados algunos con
falta de ritmo si bien tiene muy buenos
nombres sobre el papel a la de poderlos
poner en el campo nunca el entrenador
encontró la mejor expresión de los
futbolistas entre las lesiones y la baja
de rendimiento de algunos colombia
perdió ese salto de calidad que bien
decía el corresponsal tenía en su
momento con radamel falcao garcía quien
en palabras de guardiola fue el mejor 9
del mundo y con jaime rodríguez quien
fue el goleador de una copa mundial en
brasil-2014 colombia fue perdiendo
calidad y no nos dimos cuenta y es lo
que ha pasado hoy se ha confirmado la
eliminación de la copa del mundo